NICK ORLOVE: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
My name is Nick Orlove,
and welcome to CE Chat.
We are graciously
hosting on "Cloud OnAir,"
and today we're
going to be talking
about a super exciting subject--
startups.
So here with me is Jason--
Jason on the startup team.
You want to introduce
yourself real quick, Jason?
JASON SCOTT: Hi, everyone.
My name is Jason Scott.
I'm the startup program
lead for the West Coast
here on Google Cloud.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much, Jason.
It's always great to have other
teammates-- other Googlers--
joining us.
We have a special surprise,
in that later this episode
we actually have a
customer, LiftIgniter,
who's going to be jumping in and
talking about their experience
with the startup program.
But Jason, startups
are an exciting breed.
They're lightning fast,
they make changes on a dime,
they're hypersensitive
to costs, and they want
to be on the bleeding edge.
So I'm just curious.
I didn't really know that
GCP had to startup program
until quite recently.
So what is the startup program,
and what is it that you do?
JASON SCOTT: Yes, so
the startup program.
I would say there are three big
ways that we support startups.
The first is access.
So as you know,
access to product,
whether those be Cloud
products or Firebase,
are Maps APIs if they're
doing cool things with maps.
Or even access to technical
resources as well.
So we do a lot of
technical office hours
and one-on-one architecture
reviews, things like that,
for startups.
But I would one of
the biggest things
that we provide is
just the community.
So we love connecting startups
that are building things
on GCP, and connecting them
to the outside community.
So here on the
West Coast, I love
connecting startups to partners
that we have in the ecosystem.
So accelerators
and VCs, as well as
just Googlers who are really
passionate about working
with startups.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
It's basically all about who you
know sometimes in the startup
world, so if Google is able
to help me get connected,
or help my startup get connected
with Googlers, and partners,
and VCs, and all that,
that's really awesome.
So why should a startup
kind of consider
going with maybe the GCP
startup program, as opposed
to jumping in on their own
without the GCP program
or anything like that?
JASON SCOTT: Yeah,
fundamentally, I
would say Googlers
just love startups.
And Google, I think
fundamentally also,
loves startups.
And I think whether it
be the right commitment
to Open Source, and you
see that with Kubernetes
and with TensorFlow, but
also through just a lot
of our activities
that we do as a whole.
We really believe
in the one Google.
And I am always
pleasantly surprised
when I'm able to do an event,
and I not just help people
at Cloud, but have people
come in from other teams
across Google to also
support startups.
And I think Google is one
of those few places where
you can do that, where you
actually have people that
are helping startups with
all of their infrastructure
and all their products
throughout their business model
and their other
stages of growth.
NICK ORLOVE: That's true.
Google Cloud is,
obviously, one aspect
of maybe hosting
your application,
running your application
somewhere in the cloud.
But there's a lot
of other aspects,
for instance, like
advertising, and Google
Search, and all
that, which I feel
like a startup probably needs
some guidance on or could
definitely use some guidance on.
JASON SCOTT: For sure.
It's overwhelming.
You can imagine being that
one person kind of getting
your company off the ground.
And it's really nice to
have a centralized resource,
I would say.
I love that part
of my job and being
able to be that centralized
resource for a founder
or developer that's looking to
get something off the ground.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
So I know that you're based
out of the West Coast,
but startups aren't just
based out of the West Coast.
There's a lot of them
out of San Francisco Bay,
but they're all
across the world.
So do we have a startup
program, like resources
to help them, across the
US, across the world, stuff
like that?
JASON SCOTT: For sure.
I have counterparts
across the world.
And we are covering
startups anywhere.
If you're a developer or
startup on any continent,
we have someone that could
be a resource for you.
And we have Googlers that
would be a resource for you.
We also do a lot of
things digitally,
so you're able-- once
you're in our program--
to sign up for office hours
and things like that as well.
So if you are in a
really remote location,
we try our best to get
you those resources,
and get you access to that.
No matter where you are,
hopefully we can help.
NICK ORLOVE: That's
cool, and I've definitely
helped with some of these
office hours in the past.
So it's always exciting to
get engaged with a startup,
find out how they're
using some product
on the absolute bleeding
edge, maybe something
that we didn't even think
about for one of our products--
machine learning, or big data,
or Cloud functions, or really
anything.
But it's certainly
exciting to sit down
with the customer and
kind of help guide
them on maybe some
best practices, lessons
learned, stuff like that.
So cool.
And I guess this is kind
of a biased question
because we're Google,
but I just have to ask.
So why GCP for startups?
JASON SCOTT: Why
GCP for startups?
I kind of alluded to it
a little bit earlier,
but I think we
really are kind of
made to grow with the startup.
And I would say, even our
program is designed for-- we
have a preprogram option for
people who are just getting
started thinking about
do they want to--
do they have an idea?
And that gives you a
little bit of credit,
a little bit a product
support to really just
kind of play with our products.
And then we grow with you.
And I think we're
really set up to do that
through all of our stages
of our program from start,
to spart, to surge.
And once you get to surge-- and
we'll hear a little bit from
LiftIgniter later--
there's also a lot
of opportunities
to just get your name out
there and do things like this--
be in front and
pitch your startup
and talk about your startup
to a broader audience.
So I think were
able to really grow
with you, both
infrastructurally,
but then also as a
founder, Which is something
we're really fundamentally in.
NICK ORLOVE: That
makes perfect sense.
And then I guess final
question while we have you here
is, what kind of success
stories do you have that you can
share about startups on GCP?
JASON SCOTT: So many.
Where do I start?
Everyone knows the Snapchat
story, so I won't start there,
but I meet founders
every single day that
are doing really cool things,
from leveraging machine
learning to better diagnose
patients with chronically
ill diseases, all
the way to, also,
leveraging our vision APIs to
better diagnose diseased crops
and help farmers--
to fun things-- not
that those weren't fun--
but to fun things such as using
Firebase to help users that
aren't technical
build apps that are
native on both iOS and Android.
I think you just
encounter everything.
And I'm excited to hear from
LiftIgniter, how they're
leveraging our products.
But everyday I hear a
new, exciting kind of idea
that a developer or
founders is doing,
in the way that
they're leveraging
our products to do that.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
and you touched
on something really
important, I think,
is that Google Cloud
will grow with you.
And you highlighted Snapchat.
Snapchat, at one
point, was a startup.
Maybe you could argue that
it still is a startup, maybe.
But when they first
started with Google,
they were much smaller than
they are today, obviously.
But yeah.
We scaled with them,
and now they're
able to host their
application on us.
And so that's really fantastic.
Well, I really believe that
the proof is in the pudding,
and that actually
talking to a startup
kind of proves our point.
And we can get some really
good nuggets of information
and knowledge from them.
So Jason, I'd like to thank you
for joining us on this CE Chat.
And then as we transition
to LiftIgniter,
I'll asked that
Indraneel come on camera.
JASON SCOTT: Awesome,
well thank you.
NICK ORLOVE: Thank you.
And just as a reminder
to our audience,
we do have at the
bottom of this page
a resource for you
to ask questions.
So we'll be able to answer
those questions live later
at the end of this segment,
and ask those questions
about startups, or ask those
questions about LiftIgniter.
And then as one
final point, make
sure that you keep
watching the webinar
because, as Jason has hinted,
we do have a special program
at the very end where you might
be able to get some GCP startup
credits.
So very cool.
Indraneel, thank
you for joining us.
And you are the
founder of LiftIgniter.
That's really awesome.
Would you mind introducing
yourself, and maybe sharing
what LiftIgniter does?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Absolutely.
Thanks for having me here, Nick.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So LiftIgniter is
a machine learning
personalization company.
And the best way
to think about that
is, you think of a
site like YouTube,
where every time
you watch a video,
a few videos are picked
automatically for you
to watch next.
And most of you who
spend time on YouTube
know how addicting it is.
But what you may not
realize is behind the scenes
there is this
enormously powerful
artificial intelligence software
that is picking videos for you
from a pool of
billions of videos.
And it's doing it
for every single user
that comes to this site.
It's an enormously
difficult problem.
But once we do it right, if
you can pick the right video
that a user is interested
in watching next,
you will create that
addictive experience,
which means end users have a
much more satisfying experience
on YouTube.
And it also means that they will
spend less time on other sites.
So it's a critical thing for
the website owners to have,
and it's an important component
of the user experience.
And the only way to make
this possible at scale
in this attention economy
is to have intelligence
behind the scenes, which is
only possible through machine
learning and more
recent AI techniques.
So that is what
LiftIgniter tries
to bring to the rest of
the world, which may not
be able to hire the
same kind of engineers
as Google or Facebook
can, or build
the kind of infrastructure
that they can.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, that's
an interesting point.
So essentially, you're
taking the concept
behind YouTube
recommendations and all that,
and then applying them to,
really, all of your customers
out there.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Exactly.
The concept of personalization
has been around
since the start of the internet.
You had personalization
companies even in '99.
What has truly changed
is-- and we always
knew that in order to
do personalization,
you need to build
intelligence at scale.
And what has changed recently
is massive breakthroughs
in machine learning,
massive breakthroughs
in cloud computing.
The presence of cloud
computing solutions
and amazing
infrastructure has made
it possible for startups
like us to actually build
these solutions and make it
available at a reasonable price
to the rest of the world.
And this is why the genesis
of such solutions happened
in companies like
Google and Facebook,
which had the absolute
state-of-the-art
in infrastructure and some
of the best engineers,
massive resources.
But now it's come to a point,
with these waves of advances
in machine learning and
cloud computing, that it
can be made available to the
rest of the world via startups
like LiftIgniter.
NICK ORLOVE: That's
really awesome.
And it's so exciting
that you guys
are pretty much on the
breaking edge of doing this
and it's really thanks
to machine learning.
So I guess some of
the basic questions
is, how or when did
you found LiftIgniter,
and why did you get into the
space in the first place?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, LiftIgniter actually
has an interesting
genesis story.
So I was part of the
Google research team
that built out several of the
major personalization systems
at Google, including
that of YouTube.
So I got to see firsthand
what a massive impact
in a true real-time
machine learning at scale
can have on customer
satisfaction,
on business metrics
for the website owners.
And so I felt like
this technology
had to be made available
at a reasonable price point
for the rest of the world.
And so this was about
four years ago, and so
basically that was the story.
That was the inspiration--
some of the breakthroughs
that happened in
companies inside Google
and saw similar breakthroughs
happening at Facebook.
We felt like this
needed to be made
available to the
rest of the world.
NICK ORLOVE: And then
from a high level,
how exactly does it work?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: So there's
a lot of things going on
behind the scenes,
but what we do
is we look at two kinds of data.
We look at user activities on
the site very, very carefully.
And then we look at
the kind of signal
that you can extract out
of the content itself,
through NLP, through
image features extraction,
through video analysis.
And taking all this
data-- this data
becomes very large very quickly.
NICK ORLOVE: Of course.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: And
what we need to do with this
data is actually
even more difficult.
So there are three things
that we need to do.
We need to do sophisticated
modeling in order
to be able to guess what a
complex creature like a human
being might want next.
We need to do this modeling at
scale, because as we discussed,
the data blows up really fast.
And finally, the
third piece is we
need to do it really, really
fast in the order of 100
milliseconds per visit.
And these three things,
scalability, complex modeling,
and real time, they don't
really go well with each other
unless you have
built fantastic--
you have access to fantastic
infrastructure, fantastic
mathematical algorithms.
So we kind of put
all that together.
And what ends up
happening is you
have a truly dynamic
experience on the website.
So when a user comes,
like a site like YouTube,
they might be showing
sports on the top row.
But you might be interested
in music right now.
And within a few clicks, the
algorithms have figured out
you're in the mood for music.
So when you go back
to your home page,
the first row is
now showing music.
So that kind of intelligence
that can dynamically
personalize every element,
it's possible only
when you combine really
sophisticated modeling,
using user behavior and
content at scale in real time.
NICK ORLOVE: I'm
always fascinated
with machine learning
use cases because it
seems like machine learning
sometimes can solve everything.
Obviously it can't, so I just
want to hear your opinion.
What, in your application,
has machine learning
worked really well with?
And then maybe what are some
of the challenges that you've
had with machine learning,
where machine learning might not
be the best use case?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Absolutely.
So machine learning-- if you
can focus and narrow down
a use case and gather
enough data for it,
machine learning can
be a great solution.
And so it's funny.
Machine learning
has so much buzz
around machine learning now.
But there are-- and it
can infuse and improves
almost every product.
It can be infused
in every product,
but it has to fit in
natural grooves nicely.
So for instance, there aren't--
machine learning can't suddenly
predict that a certain dress
someone wore on
an Oscar night is
going to resonate with a lot
of users, which a marketer
or someone who has
domain expertise
might have a lot
of intuition for.
So it's imperative that
machine learning algorithms,
which can crunch a lot
of data really fast,
do complicated things, be
paired with human intelligence,
which can make these leaps
through vast more experience
and more sophisticated,
cognitive models that
algorithms cannot do, typically.
So we are really, I
would say, scratching
the beginnings of where we
are from a sophistication
perspective.
And so it still needs to be a
big partnership between humans
and machine learning to
be truly driving value.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, that's
a really interesting point.
I find that machine
learning can be a little bit
challenging to get
into, specifically
for some of those reasons.
And it's awesome
that Google is kind
of releasing more and more
products like AutoML and stuff
like that, that can kind of
meet the user halfway, and not
just provide an ML API,
but allow them to put some
of their secret sauce, some of
the customization on top of it.
But you're absolutely hit on a
correct point in that, in order
to do machine learning, you have
to have a whole bunch of data
in order to train the model.
But not only do
you need the data,
but you need to be able
to have data that's clean,
that's been sanitized.
So some of those processes
have to be aided by people,
by ETO processes.
Stuff like that.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah,
it's actually a lot of work
to get the integration right
because algorithms are very
sensitive to feedback data.
A lot of things have to fall
into place before it can work.
When it does work,
it works like magic.
But we're still, as I said,
just scratching the surface.
There are lots more things
that can't be done by machine
learning than can be done.
NICK ORLOVE: And is there
a success story that you're
able to share with us?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, absolutely.
This is a very
common example of how
we are used by our customers.
So this is a site which has a
lot of high-end fashion items,
and we are personalizing
a grid of products
that are shown to a user.
This grid is fully responsive.
As the user navigates
through the site,
as they click on
different items,
within a sub-second-- within
actually 100 milliseconds--
when they revisit the
grid after navigating
the site for a
little bit of time,
it has completely changed
to reflect the kind of mood
they might be in--
the kind of references
that the algorithm has
inferred the user might be in.
When you do that, you
see the kind of results
that you see here are
improvements and user
engagement, the time
they spend site,
dollars they spend on the site.
Because they're
finding the products
they want by double digit
percentage [INAUDIBLE],,
which are huge.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, and I like
your example of, essentially,
user initially goes
to the site, and they
see all sorts of different
items-- dresses, shirts,
purses, all that-- but then
when they start clicking
on some purses, you
can kind of infer
that the user is maybe
more searching for purses
rather than all their
other clothing items.
So that makes sense.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, and it's
important to do
this in real time
because you never really
know who the user is,
even if they have logged in.
Which, by the way, 90% of
the users are not logged in.
And even if they're logged
in, it might be their spouse,
or it might be
their kids using it.
So their mood right now cannot
be informed by two-years-old
worth of purchasing data.
So it has to react in real time.
The best signal
for what a user is
going to do in the
next five seconds
is given by what they did
in the last five seconds.
And you have to build a
truly real-time machine
learning solution to that.
NICK ORLOVE: That makes sense.
And are you able to walk through
some of your architecture
with us?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, absolutely.
And just to give you a sense
of the scale we are at,
which necessitates pretty
sophisticated architecture,
we're processing
tens of billions
of user activities
per month, which is--
NICK ORLOVE: No small feat.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: It is.
We used to joke at some
point we were processing
more than a billion page views
per engineer in our company.
So things that were absolutely
not possible 10 years ago--
so we're definitely leveraging
all the latest technology
in a very critical way.
But we process tens of
thousands of events per second.
We score millions of
content per second
to figure out the
right match for a user.
We have billions of
signals that we analyze.
And all of this requires
a really sophisticated
architecture, which I
can describe in a second.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
let's do that.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: So
we're on GCP, obviously.
And we use a variety of
pieces of their technology.
This is a highly simplified
diagram, just so that--
NICK ORLOVE: More arrows.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah,
there are a lot more pieces,
a lot more arrows.
But this already shows how we
critically use real pieces.
So we have-- and as I've said,
probably the most common word
I've used is real time.
So we have lots of
pieces to make as much
of the processing in
real time as possible.
So, for instance,
we have a cluster--
an autoscaling cluster of
front-end computing instances,
which receive a mass--
this fire hose of events.
Then we process them through
the Google Cloud Pub/Sub message
queue, and then behind the
consumers of those message
queue are these real-time
jobs that are also
on autoscaling clusters.
One thing we use here
is-- to keep costs low,
which is critical
for startups-- is
we use preemptible instances
which are much more cheap.
Because our real-time jobs, they
require less strict guarantees
because it's
statistical systems.
If there is a little
bit of loss of data,
that's fine for the machine
learning algorithms.
So we can keep flexible,
preemptible cluster running.
All of that data goes
into our data store,
which is a core piece of
our infrastructure, which
supports hundreds of thousands
of rewrites per second.
and that is built on a cluster
of Google computing instances.
We use a variety
of cloud storage.
We use BigQuery-- very critical.
I personally think BigQuery is
a fantastic piece of software.
It has eliminated several
quarters worth of development
that you would have
had to do otherwise
in order to create
real-time analytics.
And it's a great tool for
non-technical customers,
or non-technical
members of our company
to analyze data as well.
And finally, from the
machine learning side,
we built a lot of that
machine learning in-house,
but we also use some of
some deep learning APIs,
like for vision and NLP,
for which Google has
the state-of-the-art, the
best APIs around at a very
reasonable cost.
NICK ORLOVE: So I'm just
a little bit curious.
Looks like a lot of
your machine learning
happens in GC, rather than
maybe the Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
So would you mind just adding
some context of why you
went with one versus the other?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah,
some of it is historical.
As we'll cover, we
weren't originally on GCP.
In fact, we started
before a Google Cloud
was a big enterprise.
So we had to build a lot of
our own machine learning.
Some of it is because we do
very custom machine learning
solutions, which are not
available as free tools.
But that said, we use
some ready-made APIs,
we use a lot of the
tools like TensorFlow,
and a variety of some
other open source.
And I think as we
move ahead, we're
going to use way more of
the machine learning tools
at Google.
And in fact, I think this might
be a nice segue to the story
behind us moving into GCP.
One of the reasons we are
excited about Google Cloud,
we made the transition
to Google Cloud,
is having been at
Google, I know firsthand
what a fantastic
infrastructure they have,
but also that they are
some of the leaders.
They have some of the
best machine learning.
They're by far, I think,
the best machine learning
technology in the world.
And we want to have
a piece of that.
We are a machine
learning company.
We don't want to
compromise on that.
And so we absolutely believe--
and we're very excited to try
some of the new hardware, some
of the new open source,
some of the new services
that Google Cloud is releasing.
NICK ORLOVE: It's
always interesting
hearing the
advancements that Google
is coming out with, specifically
around machine learning,
big data.
Cloud Next, which
happened recently,
I feel like maybe a quarter
of the announcements
had machine learning
on it because it seems
like machine learning is
coming to every single product
that we have.
And it just makes sense.
So it's really interesting.
I'm a little bit
curious about your story
from migrating from another
cloud provider onto GCP.
How was the migration, and
any kind of lessons learned?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
We started LiftIgniter
about four years
ago, and Google Cloud
was in a much more
restricted form then.
A major provider was AWS, and
it was not a difficult choice
at that point.
And then fast forward to
some time early last year.
We were compelled by a
lot of the offerings.
First of all, we
were very excited
that Google was taking the
cloud business seriously
because for a
variety of reasons,
I think it makes a lot of sense.
They have some of the
best infrastructure.
It's some insane infrastructure
internally at Google,
and making that available
to the rest of the world
is an idea that excites
me, appeals to me.
And to some extent, LiftIgniter
had that same spirit
of taking--
and so we were compelled
to take a very close look.
And there were a few reasons
that convinced us that
the migration-- even though the
migration is going to be very
painful for startups--
it still makes sense.
And that's a big decision coming
from a series A-level company
to make.
And that's the main
thing [INAUDIBLE]
bet on machine learning,
and that Google
is going to remain the
leader, and they're
going to expose some of the
best machine learning technology
on the cloud.
The second thing
was we were very
impressed by the people
we interacted with
and their commitment
to helping startups.
And startups need money.
Startups need great access
to great technology.
But another thing
they really would like
is marketing exposure.
And it's events like
this, for instance.
Google has been phenomenal.
We've had a ton of
exposure through blogs,
through conferences,
through events like this
at getting our message out.
So that was very, very
compelling for us.
That was something we
were willing to take
a hit on engineering
productivity for a few months
during the migration.
There were a few other
business reasons,
like a lot of our customers
our e-commerce customers.
And they're not
really comfortable
being vendors that are
completely hosted on AWS,
for obvious reasons.
And then a few other
things, like obviously,
infrastructures on certain
pieces was more exciting.
The pricing was
friendlier in many ways.
And so all of these reasons
together, we just made a call.
And I think we were very
glad that we actually
made that decision.
NICK ORLOVE: Well, hats
off to Jason and team.
That startup program
is phenomenal, working
with customers and everything.
So that's very awesome.
Can you share some of the
things that LiftIgniter
is going to be coming
out with in the future?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Yes, absolutely.
So when we initially started--
I'm a machine learning
PhD in my background.
It was all about machine, or
let's make the best algorithms.
What we realized is, there are
limitations of the algorithm.
There are things that a
human does much better.
And in order to build
a full-fledged product,
we need to kind of
balance those two things.
So we have this concept
of augmented intelligence.
So we have these machine
learning algorithms,
but working for you--
working as tools that marketers
can use, in the same way
that in Google Cloud is
making tools available rather
than solutions to
replace human beings.
So that is our focus,
and we're coming up
with a lot of tools
for technical,
as well as non-technical
people, to leverage
the sophisticated
machine learning.
Use the insights from
them, use them as tools
to achieve their ends.
So that's one of the
most exciting things
we have on our roadmap.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
Yeah, that's awesome.
And then last question
for you before we
jump into some of the
Q&A. How do people
get in touch with LiftIgniter?
I've heard that you're looking
for maybe some new people
to join the team, and obviously
looking for customers.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah, so
if you want to test the product,
just send us an email
at info@liftigniter.com.
We will get on a call
with you right away.
We have a lot of information
on the website as well.
And we're, obviously, looking
for amazing machine learning,
back end, front end engineers,
marketing, as well as
non-technical folks on the
sales and marketing site.
So just drop us a note
at jobs@liftigniter.com,
and we'll get back to you.
NICK ORLOVE: Well,
Indraneel, thank
you so much for spending
the time with us.
We're going to take
a quick break for all
of the questions that
have been submitted,
so we can compile
them into one slide.
And then we're going to
have you and Jason back
to go over some
of those answers.
So they can very much.
Appreciate it.
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Thanks so much, Nick.
JASON SCOTT: All
right, everyone.
Welcome back.
Again, Jason Scott, startup
program lead on the West Coast
here at Google Cloud.
And we have Indraneel here,
founder of LiftIgniter.
And we're back for
a few questions.
So you want to just kick it off?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
Sure, absolutely.
JASON SCOTT: Awesome.
So first question we have.
So now that LiftIgniter has
been on GCP for a while,
are there some
things you wish you
had known from the beginning?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think, definitely-- we
received a lot of help
from Google team
while migrating,
but there were a few things we
just could have planned better
during migration.
So anyone who is planning
to migrate from, let's
say AWS or some
other cloud provider,
to GCP, it's good to
probably dive down
into some of the technologies,
which may look similar.
For instance, [INAUDIBLE],,
which is a message queue on AWS
versus Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
there are some subtle
differences that can change
how much money it cost you,
change how much--
what kind of throughput
you're achieving.
So both on the technical,
as well as expense side,
you might want to redo
your code in a certain way
in order to best use the
new technology that you
are migrating to.
So some of the things
we thought were
straightforward
may not be, so it's
good to take a closer look
while doing the migration.
That was the theme
behind several pieces.
For instance, the
streaming jobs as well.
When we went from streaming
jobs that were mostly self--
it was managed by us
to Cloud Dataflow,
there were some differences,
which were a pleasant surprise.
And there were some others
which were unexpected,
and we have to kind of maneuver.
But if we had just known a
few more details in advance,
it would have helped with
a smoother transition.
JASON SCOTT: Well, you made
it, which is also great.
Second question that
came from the audience.
Any words of wisdom, I
guess aside from the one
that you just mentioned,
for other aspiring startups
and founders out there?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Yeah, there
is a lot of wisdom out there.
I don't think--
I would strongly
recommend looking
at Y Combinator's content.
We actually went
through Y Combinator.
And if you are a
first time founder,
I would say that's one
of the best places.
You look up their
startup school advice,
look at their course
loads, and I would strongly
recommend going through
that program as well.
But beyond that, startups
are exhilarating.
It's like you're going to live
life in a more intense way.
So brace for it, but its
going to be worth it.
JASON SCOTT: Third, and you
mentioned the challenges
of migration already, but
what are some of the benefits
and challenges-- some of the
other benefits and challenges
that LiftIgniter faced on
GCP throughout your journey?
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE:
The benefits, again--
I kind of touched
upon these issues,
like the pricing
is much friendlier.
It helps us reduce planning
and some extra overhead.
It's easier to sell to
some of our customers,
again, the e-commerce customers.
Some of the tools are
just a little bit more
developer-friendly.
I keep hearing this from
a lot of our developers,
like the permission system
is a little more friendly.
Google Cloud
Pub/Sub, it has a lot
of-- and Cloud Dataflow,
they are very well-designed
services, which reduces
the coding complexities.
There have been like
innumerable little things
like that, which we really like.
And then, of course,
some big things
like BigQuery, which is a
phenomenal piece of product,
infrastructure.
It has simplified a lot of our
product, and it has cut down
are dev time by several months.
Totally worth the price.
And some of the
autoscaling logic,
et cetera, which has also
worked pretty well for us.
And so that was some
of the benefits.
The challenges, again,
some more better research
before doing the migration could
have helped us create a better
plan for migration.
And then the other thing is,
Google Cloud has some fantastic
features, but there
are some rough edges.
Not many, but some, like for
instance, a load balancer
ran down a few weeks ago.
And then there were some
minor bits and pieces.
There was just a little
bit more monitoring--
less monitoring metrics
that are available,
which is kind of
important for us
because we have strong
SLAs with our customers.
Again, nothing-- these
aren't showstoppers.
These are all things
we can work around.
And I'm sure these will
improve very quickly,
given the pace at which
Google Cloud has improved
over the last few years.
JASON SCOTT: Well, thank
you for being candid.
I guess the last question
is one that I can take.
It says, if I'm a startup, how
do I get engaged with Google?
So I think with
that, I would love
to let everyone know
that as a viewer
or as a listener
to this, you're all
eligible to join our
startup program at our start
tier, which is kind of our early
stage tier for our program.
That includes $3,000 in Cloud
credits and Firebase credits,
as well as a lot
of other benefits--
G Suite, if you're on that, as
well as the technical support
that we mentioned
earlier as well.
With that, I would
like everyone to stay
tuned for our next session,
which is Google Sheets--
tips and tricks to
boost productivity.
Something I definitely
will also tune into.
Coming to you live
from New York.
And with that, thank you,
Indraneel, for coming.
Thank you to everyone
for listening in,
and we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]